Are you having difficulty opening up in a relationship?
Life is about being courageous,
but this doesn't mean you don't fear.
It's natural to be doubtful or uncertain when you take a risk.
The same can be said of being in a relationship.
You don't stop being afraid
just because you're romantically involved with the person.
Rather, it allows you to grow
even if it means failure or heartache.
You have the benefit of building something worthwhile and
fulfilling.
Here are 6 ways to be vulnerable in love.
1. Admit and own up to your mistake.
Our pride and ego can ruin our relationship with our
partner when we worry more about
being judged by them than admitting our flaws.
Granted, it's not comfortable letting your guard down
and allowing someone else to see your not-so-good side
quirks and all.
But being self-aware and viewing ourselves in a healthy
manner will help us grow and improve
personally contributing to a relationship.
2. Listen to your partner's needs and difficulties without quickly trying to problem-solve.
without quickly trying to problem-solve.
Well, it's always good to quickly solve problems
so that they don't stress you out unnecessarily.
Sometimes, it's not always easy to think straight
when your emotions are all over the place.
Being vulnerable means putting yourself
in your partner's shoes. It means not only
being in touch with your own emotions
but the emotions of your partner's ,too.
You're essentially mindful of the pain or the stress that they're
going through. This will help you realize
that maybe all they really need is a shoulder
to cry on and not just the solution.
3. Learn to let go of your control.
If you have a strong leader personality,
it may be difficult for you to give up the reins
and allow your partners to take the initiative. In order to be
vulnerable, you need to allow your partners to make
decisions for both of you at times.
If you don't, you could seem dismissive or hard to
approach in times of disagreements.
Vulnerability is a good thing
because it shows that you trust your partner so it's good to let
go every once in a while.
4. Hold onto who you are without allowing
shame or embarrassment stop you from being real.
Maintain a strong sense of self and never feel
as if you have to done yourself down
or worry about being to nice. If you are a bookworm
or a philanthropist, do  with wills
right and natural for you. It's perfectly OK
to have opinions and perspectives that are different
from your partners.
Never compromise who you are to be with someone.
You also shouldn't have to always rely on your partner
to make you feel better about yourself.
because that would be codependency,
not vulnerability. It's important to know
when to assert yourself.
5. Check in with reality.
Geraldine K. Piorkowski, author of
Too Close For Comfort: Exploring The Risks Of Intimacy
writes: Rather than invalidating what you're feeling,
it can help to have a different perspective on whether your emotions
and actuals that follow them
are in lying with the facts of what's actually happening.
Insecurity can make you distort your reality.
It's important then to ask your partners to help you
figure out what's real or not.
For example, if you think that your partner is cheating on you,
it could be that you're affected by your
own personal
past experience. Make it a habit to check in with reality
so that you don't jump into conclusions without
concrete evidence.
6.
Help your partner feel safe.
Vulnerability is not
just about your needs, thoughts and emotions.
It's also about your partner's needs,
thoughts and emotions. It's better to establish
communication that allows both you and your partner
the space to express yourselves freely
rather than bottling up your emotions.
Show your partner you have their best interests at heart
by encouraging them to let you in at a pace that
they are comfortable with. Do so in a
non-pushy, non-aggressive manner.
Love can't be forced, nor rushed,
but it can always be well.What is holding your heart back?
Share your thoughts below.
If you enjoy this video, please like and subscribe to see
more content from Psych2Go. Thank you for watching!(â¤)